hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one of the key and Central topics
that William James is going to approach
and explore and actually take an
important stand on in his address the
will to believe is the connection
between what he calls certitude which
you can also translate as
certainty and Truth itself and this is
going to start in section five where he
says that the faith that truth exists
and that our minds can find it may be
held in two ways we may talk about the
empiricist and the absolutist way of
belie beleving in truth and notice that
he's using the word belief there right
not saying that we absolutely have
knowledge that's going to come a little
bit later he uh also uses this term
Faith right so this is quite important
and so there's different ways of doing
this he says that the absolutists in
this manner say that we not only can't
attain to knowing truth but we can know
when we have attained to knowing it so
we can have knowledge about our own
state of knowledge whilst the
empiricists think that although we may
attain it we cannot
infallibly know when and that infallibly
there's a very important
qualifier he's not saying that we can't
know that we know something if we're an
empiricist he's just saying we can't
infallibly know that we know the truth
in you know most
circumstances right and so he goes on he
says to know is one thing and to know
for certain there's that certitude that
we know is another you can hold to the
first being possible without the second
and so they show very different degrees
of
dogmatism in how they approach the truth
empiricists are less dogmatic and
absolutists are more dogmatic IC right
so then he's going to talk about what he
calls Scholastic Orthodoxy now does this
only mean
scholasticism of the Middle Ages early
modern period late modern period as we
might find say among certain Tomas no no
this covers a lot of ground you could be
a Scholastic uh Orthodox uh subscribing
person from a variety of different
viewpoints so he says Scholastic
Orthodoxy to which one must always go
when one wishes to find a perfectly
clear statement has beautifully
elaborated this absolutist conviction in
a Doctrine which it calls that of
objective evidence and then he says if
for example I'm unable to doubt that I
now exist before you that two is less
than three or if all men are mortal then
I am mortal to it is because these
things illumin my intellect IR
irresistibly and then he's going to
launch into some Latin phrases here
which I'll translate for you because
maybe you don't know Latin he's assuming
an audience that actually does know it
as his address he says that the Final
Ground of this objective evidence
possessed by certain propositions is the
adio intellectus no Kum re so the
adequation or the
correspondence between our intellect
with the thing the matter itself and
then he says the certitude it brings
involves an optitude
extor
quum sensum on the part of the truth and
Visage so what is that a aptitude or
disposition to uh demanding to imposing
to you know bringing out of it a certain
Ascent not certain as like a kind of
ascent but an absolutely certain ascent
on the part of the truth envisaged and
on the side of the subject a qum in cogn
right if we want to be very literal
about this a quiet but resting in the
cognition the knowledge that it has when
Once the object is mentally received
that leaves no possibility of Doubt
behind and the whole transaction
operates nothing but the antias ipsa of
the object and the antias ipsa of the
Mind The Entity itself the being the the
you know what makes it what it is of the
object and what makes the mind what it
is okay so you know this could be that
of uh so Mystic scholasticism but this
could also be so many others as well do
we ever really have something like this
and he says we slouchy modern thinkers
dislike to talk in Latin indeed we
dislike to talk in set terms at at all
but our own State of Mind is very much
like this when we
uncritically abandon ourselves and so
people may pretend that they're Skeptics
or empiricists but they're never truly
such and it's very easy to believe as he
says in something like this objective
evidence he says the greatest
empiricists Among Us are only empir on
reflection when left to their instincts
they dogmatize like infallible popes and
he talks about Clifford somebody who
he's he's targeting in this um telling
us how sinful it is to be Christians on
such insufficient evidence insufficiency
is really the last thing they have in
mind for them the evidence is absolutely
sufficient only it makes it the other
way they believe so completely in an
anti-christian order of the universe
there's no living option right so you
know know we're we're very often even if
we claim to be empiricists we fall into
absolutism and something like this
notion of objective uh you know
objective evidence or certainty or
certitude or something along those lines
now in the next section number
six he'll say okay if we are such
absolutist by Instinct what should we do
as philosophers should we we endorse
this should we treat it as a weakness of
our our nature and James says I
sincerely believe the latter course is
the only one we can follow as reflective
Men objective evidence and certitude are
doubtless as he's going to call it fine
ideals to play with but where are they
to be found and so he says I am going to
be a complete empiric IST as far as this
matter goes right I'm going to endorse
uh empiricism as far as my theory of
human knowledge goes and so how is this
going to work well he's going to say
what can we actually be completely
certain about and he says the only thing
that pyonium skepticism so the most uh
extreme form of skepticism leaves behind
is one
inecta certain truth and what is it the
present phenomenon of Consciousness
exists so this goes even Beyond decart's
I think therefore I am which is the
archimedian point as he calls it by
which he can reconstruct everything else
turns out that that deart actually
believes in a whole bunch of other
things that he's he's using to
reconstruct the world in his own form of
skepticism so um James is saying this is
the only thing that that you can be like
totally certain of in that
way and he goes on and he says um that's
fine we can have that um but that's the
bare starting point of knowledge the
mere admission of a stuff to be
philosophized about so the different
philosophies are attempts at expressing
what this stuff what it is that we're
philosophizing about really is and what
happens when we actually go to
our libraries can we find a certainly
true answer and he says well aside from
propositions and here's an example of
one um that 2 plus 2 are equal to four
or we could use the earlier two is less
than three mathematical propositions so
he says apart from abstract propositions
of comparison propositions which tell us
nothing by by themselves about concrete
reality now he's not saying that you
can't apply mathematics to concrete
Reality by themselves those propositions
don't tell us anything about the world
we experience right they are abstract so
he goes on and he says aside from these
we find no proposition ever regarded by
anyone as evidently certain so there's
all sorts of propositions that people
have to be evidently certain to them and
they put them forward as if they were to
everyone so we find no proposition that
has not either been called a falsehood
or at least had its truth sincerely
questioned by someone else so this is a
problem right every Claim about this
objective evidence or you know absolute
certainty that every reasonable human
being can recognize winds up being
contested if we're being honest with
ourselves if we're being empiricists and
looking at the history of ideas if we're
going through the library and opening up
books and seeing what people are
actually saying and then what other
people are saying about that so that
should be you know a a significant issue
right especially when we see people
making claims about object Ive evidence
and and
certainty so that's you know an example
he says you know the transcending of the
axioms of geometry and the rejection of
the whole Aristotelian logic by the
hegelians are great examples of this and
we could multiply even more examples of
this and then he says no concrete test
of what is really true has ever been
agreed upon and he's going to give us a
whole bunch of examples of this what are
they some make the Criterion external to
the moment of perception putting it in
Revelation right it's in some religious
text or the consensus gentium now the
consensus gentium is an old-fashioned
way of talking about everybody believes
this or everybody who's reasonable
believes this and it was used for
example as a very weak argument for the
existence of God or The God or the
divine all the way back in Cicero's time
because Cicero puts it in the mouth of
one of his interlocutors in on the
nature of the Gods it's a terrible
argument right just it could be that
everybody is wrong about that or the
instincts of the heart right that's
something extra rational the
systematized experience of the race he's
talking about you know people who are
kind of sloppy loose social darwinists
or pick whatever else you want others
make the perceptive moment its own test
so for example dayart with his clear and
distinct ideas guaranteed by his
veracity of God not everybody buys that
including you know some of James own
contemporaries like Charles purse for
example Thomas Reed with his Common
Sense man anytime you see an appeal to
common sense you know that somebody is
kind of like at the limits of what it is
that they're they're you know trying to
justify because it's not a very good um
ground at all Kant with his forms of
synthetic judgment op priori Kant thinks
that everybody has to buy into this you
don't have to and you know his
successors didn't uh necessarily do that
so he says the inconceivability of the
opposite the capacity to be verified by
sense the possession of complete organic
Unity or self- relation a heg alian
approach to it realize when a thing is
its own other all of these are standards
that have been used none of them
actually have anything even close to
Universal Ascent if we look through the
history of philosophy every single one
of them not only has been as he says
contested by somebody there's a whole
bunch of people who say this is not
actually even true so that's a big
problem isn't it there's no concrete
test that has Universal
consensus um so what does this mean he
says this objective evidence never
triumphantly there it is as he says a
mere
aspiration or Gren begriff now a Gren
begriff a limit concept this is a German
term that was used quite a bit something
that you can't actually meet with this
is actually you can find this in Kant
for example and in so many of his
successors so this objective evidence
that we say is there doesn't turn out to
really be there every one of these
things is rather subjective um this is
starting to look pretty bad isn't it and
he'll go on and say um here we go what a
contradictory array of opinions have
objective evidence and absolute
certitude been claimed and so here's a
listing of examples and we could add so
many other examples to this the world is
rational through and through its
existence is an ultimate brute fact
those can't both be true at the same
time time people have maintained them as
if they are you know absolute
certainties um there is a personal God a
personal God is inconceivable again two
uh things that can't possibly both be
true maybe they're both wrong right
there's an extramental physical world
immediately known the mind can only know
its own ideas same sort of deal a moral
imperative exists obligation is only the
resultant of desires a permanent
spiritual principle is in everyone there
are only shifting States a mind there is
an endless chain of causes there is an
absolute first cause an eternal
necessity a freedom a purpose no purpose
a primal one a primal many a universal
continuity an essential discontinuity in
things an Infinity no Infinity there is
this there is that there is indeed
nothing which someone has not thought
absolutely true while his neighbor
deemed it absolutely false so these
examples cover the gamut of
epistemology metaphysics moral
philosophy uh philos philosophy of
religion we could have gone into
politics we could have gone into
Aesthetics we could pick anything that
you
want and somebody's going to say this is
absolutely true and then there's
somebody else who's like nope don't buy
into it you're wrong about that but this
over here is absolutely true quite often
they're going to jump from one certitude
to another why is James giving us all
all these examples because he wants to
drive this point home to us right so he
he goes on and says um here we go
uh every single one of these things H
has been you know considered to be true
by some person and somebody has
contested it not an Absolut among them
seems ever to consider that the trouble
may be essential this may may be in fact
endemic to our use of the human mind in
relation to our experience and
generalizing about the way things are
and about how well we can know them and
so he says the intellect even with truth
directly in its grasp may have no
infallible signal for knowing whether it
be truth or not so we can have truth but
it doesn't seem as if we can have
objective evidence or absolute certainty
that it is indeed true and even if we
can have the feeling of it or the belief
in it subjectively for ourselves or with
a bunch of our own you know uh people
that agree with us that we hang out with
that we read books together with in some
sort of school or tradition or some sort
of uh approach to things the fact that
there's others who say no no that
doesn't work that's that's a problem for
us isn't it so he says all right what
are the implications of this should we
all become Skeptics and say ah there's
no truth whatsoever we can't know
anything other than for example that you
know Consciousness the phenomenon of
Consciousness exists in the present
James says no we don't have to get so
pessimistic about things from there he
says when as empiricists we give up the
doctrine of objective certitude we don't
give up and notice these two words the
quest or the hope of Truth
itself I think those are very important
hope something that we can't say we have
absolute certainty in but hope is what
allows us to do some of what he's
talking about later on in it you know to
engage in the kinds of action and
decision that would allow us to actually
come across certain truth and it has to
be a quest we continue trying to seek
the truth even if we recognize that when
we find it we're probably not going to
be absolutely certain about it and even
if we feel that we're absolutely certain
somebody else is going to say nah that's
not absolutely certain and its opposite
is absolutely certain he says we still
pin our faith on its existence truth's
existence and we still believe we gain
an Ever better position towards it by
systematically continuing to roll up
experiences so paying attention to
things and having experiences and think
now here's what he says that's really
quite important the our our great
difference from the Scholastic the
absolutist lies in the way we face now
what it means there is what direction
we're looking where we are taking our
focus and it's talks about a difference
between a Terminus
aquo and a Terminus adem again Latin
terms right Terminus an end a goal and
aquo from which right uh so our starting
points you could say and then Odem where
we're going so the absolutist as he's
going to say the strength of his system
lies in the principles the origin the
Terminus aquo of his thought what makes
him certain is that he began from the
right starting points and then he began
deducing things or whatever other mode
of inference he's using to get to some
results now James says that the
empiricist and here you can recognize
that the empiricist is also a
pragmatist um he says the strength is in
the outcome the upshot the Terminus OD
quem not where it comes from but what it
leads to is to decide we want to
see where things are going what sort of
results they produce for us and that is
what allows us to say the things are
true perhaps without an absolute
certitude behind them now there is one
other thing that he says um in a later
section at the very end of the work in
section 10 that we want to attend
to so he uses this uh metaphor of a bell
right he says that um if we had an
infallible intellect with its objective
certitudes we might feel ourselves
disloyal to such a perfect organ of
knowledge and not trusting to it
exclusively in not waiting for it's
releasing word but if we are
empiricists if we believe that no Bell
in US TOS to let us know for certain
when truth is in our grasp then it seems
a bit of idle fantastic cality what a
great word he coins there to preach so
solemnly our duty of waiting for the
Bell a Criterion within ourselves he
says if we want to we can wait for it it
I'm not saying that you can't wait for
it I'm not denying that but if we do we
do so at our own Peril as much as if we
believed so we don't have to wait for
absolute certainty or objective evidence
or whatever other turn of phrase you
want to use to convey that same idea
something that as he points out is just
a limit concept or an aspiration we
don't have to wait for that in order to
actually say that we do attain to truth
that we do in fact know things but we
need to recognize our own limitations
and not pretend as if we have discover
the infallible way of arriving at all
truths and that all others must
recognize this because because they're
not going to the history of ideas has
shown us that that ain't going to be the
case never has been never will be is
that something we can be absolutely
certain about I leave that for you to
think about whether James is asserting
that with perfect certainty or
not
that